I am about to drive to Blackpool to go
meet a random guy called Glenn who's got
no money no experience in property and
he thinks that becoming financially free
and his situation is impossible so I'm
gonna drive to his house I'm gonna live
with him in his house for a week and the
plan is to try starting from scratch
he's a zero start to get him up to
financial freedom oh my goodness this is
ridiculous it was hard me doing getting
him from scratch but training someone
else did it again from scratch
he thinks it's impossible on the
believer but I am here in Glenn's house
she's three kids are in bed I just met
his wife what a fabulous day to be alive
it's amazing I can't believe it so we're
gonna become financially free this week
at the plan I don't know how you could
go let's do it see we're not sleeping
anytime soon here's the plan man this is
the plan we need to get in as many
houses as possible yeah so we need to
just in the morning bang bang bang bang
bang ring agents okay get in there with
agents yeah get our houses and then it
will be in the right position to start
negotiating and do what willing to do we
just need to literally get in front of
as many people as possible estate agents
deal saucers get a feel for the area get
in front of sellers you activated
sellers Mike my question to you is how
is this possible with no money because
it's not as if I have like lots of
deposits or anything I literally I have
any money so how how is this gonna work
okay
I fit the first and it raised either I
get that there's obviously things like
rent events yeah lease option agreement
yeah deal packaging but before we even
think about the strategy exactly I think
we just need to find the deals the first
thing is that we need to have deals
that's the first thing and that's our
plan that's our first step yeah so
tomorrow we're just gonna go into a
state agent speak to as many people as
possible yeah meet motivated sellers and
just try and find some property else I
am at your mercy